It's nice hey guys I am Nate I'm here back at the dome, and I am Zach from the YouTube channel  Jerry rigs everything
We've got another fun experiment that we're gonna be trying out today
We are going to melt down some aluminum until it's nice and molten hot and then we are going to pour it down
Inside this block of clear ice what do you think's gonna happen? Well I know what I think is gonna happen
I think the whole thing's gonna explode
But either way hopefully we get a cool design out of the aluminum once. It's cooled down again
I think the aluminum pouring into the block of ice might heat up the water so much that it expands and a steam just shreds
The block apart, it's possible that there won't be enough power to break the block
But instead it will shoot the aluminum out the top of the block and that would be pretty cool
Or the aluminum might just settle inside the ice melting its way and cooling down at the same time and give us some strange
Formation, I don't know which of those is gonna happen or something else entirely
But let's find out so this right here is our pouring device by pulling the pink string. It causes this to tip and
Once that's full of its molten aluminum that should pour down right into the ice
We've got some aluminum cables that are wrapped up into bundles and these will be melted intrusive
Three two one
LAUGHTER
That was amazing holy oh!
(AND IT EXPLODED!!!!!!!!!)
holy cow
My gosh that was beautiful, haha
MORE LAUGHTER
Yes, I didn't think it was going to you because I saw it pouring in and I thought oh
It's just gonna settle down inside there
That's cool
But it's not asked and right about I was thinking that's not as cool as if it exploded it exploded in a huge way
look at this like the
Explosion is probably what 10 feet out at least there's little ice at least Everywhere.That was cool
That was obliterated
Man
That was as good as I could have possibly hoped for oh well my binder. Clip is like aluminum
welded to our I
Can't get it off
(ICE SIZZLES ON HOT CRUCIBLE)
Oh
My gosh exactly what I wanted to have happen
Seriously
Man look at these shards
Just shattered pieces
It's like broken glass, too
That's really what it looks like I'll give you take it like a coke bottle or something yeah
And I think it's partly just because we're not used to seeing ice
That's so cohesive like these clear blocks of ice
They don't have the the brake lines that you would get if you had ice
It's full of air bubbles and so just really seeing ice breaking this crystalline shapes is pretty different
The outside of this cup so it poured in
At that angle and then the the aluminum exploding just completely coated this
Better coat at the bottom of this to a little bit
Let that cool down and melt its way through a block at the same time
That was amazing that was seriously one of the coolest effects. We've ever had happen on this show the explosion alone was
That thing just shattered into a trillion tiny little pieces and sent shards of ice flying really hard
I think we had some go almost 20 25 feet away, and it was loud
Really really loud. It's like the initial as we were pouring it in. I was like oh alright. That's all it's gonna happen
We're you know a little cube of aluminum that is all dry, but then BOOM
So blood projects like this are always great
And we've been doing so how long is the king of random it doing? It's been about seven years now
Yeah, I started my youtube channel about six years ago
and it's been great being able to turn my hobby into a career and
Luckily the king of random and I grant Thompson
And I have we're gonna get together with a bunch of other large youtubers and talk about how to form your hobbies on
YouTube and online into a career
It's a seminar called self-made and we'll leave a link in the video description
Where you can sign up to come and listen to us? Whether it's online or in person and establish your business online?
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to see it again
Click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow